we're remembering the life and career of
Academy award-winning actor Martin
Landau this morning the 89 year old died
over the weekend after unexpected
complication during a brief
hospitalization and there appeared in
nearly 200 movies and television shows
over his more than 60 year career now
let's not be stupid huh we tale Johnny
your place last night he went in but he
didn't come out with a dynamic range 42
a my platoon alone when we started and
an unrivaled longevity actor Martin
Landau was one of the professions most
adaptable students I wonder if I might
have a few words of parting with you sir
certainly he played an assassin in
output Hitchcock classic 1959 thriller
North by Northwest hey I've had too many
to drink and an adulterous husband in
Woody Allen's crimes and misdemeanors
mr. Lugosi why are you buying a car
thanks but it was his effort on Tim
Burton's 1994 film Ed Wood I'm ready now
roll the cabin on that earned him the
craft highest honor Martin Landau it was
his only Academy Award
don't put music on because of its a
Mission Impossible theme I'll get really
angry
Landau's work stretch generations
destiny chooses us cash with some of
today's biggest stars in both drama and
comedy I don't miss putts inside 10 feet
even Bob knows that well how would I
know that
the only putts I see is standing in
front of me ballin audience wants to
believe is what's going on between two
people it's happening for the first time
ever that is about acting boy boy boy
such diversity yeah such talent it's
hard to believe he only won one Oscar
you would think given his body of work
he probably was nominating would have
been nominated for so many more such a
great actor amazing career